[Music]
anti-war activist tariq Ali critiques
America's military occupation of Iraq
and his latest work Bush in Babylon this
talk from Johns Hopkins University in
Baltimore lasts an hour 15 minutes
um good evening and welcome everybody we
are delighted to have Terry Callie once
again with us at this evening
Tariq as you know is known to all of us
in many garbs
author speaker public intellectual
playwright and filmmaker but above all
he has been a rigorous dissenter
consistently speaking truths to bars
born in Lahore he attended Catholic
school and then moved to Oxford in the
early 1960s when his opposition to the
military dictatorship in Pakistan forced
him to flee while studying politics
philosophy and economics at Oxford he
became involved in socialist student
organizations and soon emerged as a key
figure in what was dubbed the political
underground he debated with Henry
Kissinger protested effectively against
the Vietnam War
led the infamous march on the American
Embassy in London in 1968 and edited the
revolutionary paper the black dwarf
Tariq founded an independent television
production company in the 1980s and
collaborated on plays with Howard Benton
and films with Derrick Yaman a constant
and prolific writer and speaker Tariq is
also an editor and board member of the
new left review a regular contributor to
the Guardian and London Review of Books
and is currently working on an opera
about Ayatollah Khomeini he has written
over a dozen books on history and
politics including the Islamic quartet
and four award-winning historical novels
that explore the encounter between the
Christian West and the world of Islam
his previous book The Clash of
fundamentalisms is a broad analysis of
the historical and religious roots of
the 9/11 attacks the war on terror and
the collision between rigid Islamic
fundamentalism and persistent American
anger enticement in 2003 Tariq helped to
organize the February 15th anti-war
rally in London which attracted an
audience of over a million
he is currently launching simultaneous
international editions of Bush in
Babylon his new work from which he will
be talking
to us today I now present directly for
you
[Applause]
when the events of 9/11 took place there
were two possible solutions
some of us argued that the only way to
deal with organizations like al-qaeda
was not militarily but politically that
if attempts were made to deal with them
militarily by invading countries and
occupying them terrorism would actually
increase we warned that the occupation
of Afghanistan would not lead to the
dismantling of al-qaeda and when people
asked what the solution was I remember
arguing with members of the people close
to the Bush administration pundits
associated with it and we said the
solution has to be political and this
solution has to entail solving two key
problems in the Arab East one the
continuing saw of Palestine the
continuing occupation of Palestine by
the Israelis and putting massive
pressure on the Israelis to pull out off
the occupied territories back to the
borders of sixty-seven and the emergence
of a Palestinian state with continuous
borders independent and free and not an
Israeli Protectorate the second demand
we made and the was that the sanctions
against Iraq which had crippled that
country led to the loss of half a
million children and many many more
adults over the previous 12 years the
continuous weekly bombing raids carried
on carried out on Iraq by the Americans
and the British with the backing of the
United Nations had to stop these two
problems if solved would stop the flow
of young people in the Arab world
educated people professional people to
organizations like al-qaeda there was no
really no other serious solution instead
the US administration decided to do the
exact opposite the invaded Afghanistan
occupied it occupying these countries is
not a problem if you're the world's
largest military power you can do it
it's what you do afterwards
and what happens in these countries
afterwards that matters and in
Afghanistan the situation is a complete
mess to this day some of you will recall
that at the time of the Afghanistan war
the United States or the ideologues of
the United States more or less argued
that this was a war for women's
liberation it probably if that had been
the case that would have been the first
time in the history of the world that an
imperial power has launched a war in
favor of women's liberation we had Laura
Bush and Cherie Blair the wife of the
British prime minister appearing on
television tete-a-tetes and radio talks
and pointing out the condition of women
in Afghanistan well we didn't need to be
reminded of this we knew what the
condition of Afghanistan was both of
women and of course of male citizens for
many years in the years in which the
United States was collaborating with the
organizations which were creating these
conditions in that particular country so
it was not exactly new to us but the
notion that the war was fought to bring
human rights is just a joke look at
Afghanistan today I mean if you barely
read reports of it because it's such a
total disaster the rate of the guy
imposed on Afghanistan Hamid Karzai
doesn't extend beyond Kabul as we want
he is not guarded by any Afghan soldiers
at all US Marines have to guard him
permanently which doesn't speak too well
of his support in the country if you
can't find any of if he doesn't trust
any of God's so then having done that
which incidentally as you all know
stopped failed to end the organization
known as al-qaeda then the
administration began seriously to plan
the invasion of Iraq now the reasons
they gave for the invasion of Iraq
were false the whole world now knows it
they lied they said the key reason for
invading this regime was that it
possessed weapons of mass destruction
Bush said this about 20 times in the
run-up to the war which I document in my
book Bush in Babylon
Joanie Blair his fellow conspirator in
this war said weapons of mass
destruction which could be unleashed in
reach London within 45 minutes lie total
and complete lie the politicians lied to
their citizens in order to get their
citizens ready for war and this created
a deep division in these societies a
political division in these societies
which was very unusual in Britain in
particular and to a lesser extent in the
United States leading military people
are not in favor of this adventure they
came out and said so in Britain you had
a strange experience because it's a very
secretive society where the former head
of the Joint Intelligence Committee a
former national security adviser to
Blair senior intelligence guy called Sir
Roderick Braithwaite wrote a public
letter to the Financial Times after the
occupation of book that in which he made
a ferocious attack on Blair and what had
been done in the name of this war so
it's not that the division was the usual
division of small groups on the Left
opposed to the mighty powers that be
these divisions went very deep in
societies and they went very deep in
Europe as well the scale and size of the
demonstrations was phenomenal
3 million people in Rome just one city
of Europe gens about between 10 and 15
million who marched all over the world
that indicated not that there was a
massive radicalization taking place but
that people were becoming extremely
nerve
of a big power which was out of control
which was now the only single empire in
the world and which believed it could
dominate the world at will when it
wanted to so what were the reasons for
the invasion of era what were the real
reasons if the weapons of mass
destruction were false as they patently
were in fact in reality the only reason
they could go into Iraq was that Iraq
did not have any weapons of mass
destruction if it had they wouldn't have
invaded it they knew it was a weak army
they knew it was an army which wouldn't
be able to resist and they knew that the
army had an armory which had been
depleted by years of sanctions that's
the only sort of serious effect the
sanctions had if you like the rest was
just a disaster for the population so
they knew all this when they went so why
take care of I think essentially for the
following reasons I don't think the
principal reason for taking Iraq was oil
incidentally that's always a reason when
anything happens in that part of the
world because it has the cheapest
available energy sources in the world
it's not that other parts don't have oil
this is the cheapest oil to produce and
so billions are spent every year by the
United States in shoring up what is
known euphemistically is the security of
that region i keeping large numbers of
regimes in power which are conducive to
Western interests if it had just been
oil there were other ways they could
have got the oil I mean they could have
as they've done in the past in the 70s
and 80s done a deal with the regime in
fact even during the sanctions period we
now know that the United States were
using a decoy companies elsewhere in the
world to buy Iraqi oil at the same time
as officially they had imposed sanctions
on it so it's not the case that the oil
was unobtainable I think the principal
reason for the occupation was
demonstration of imperial power not
simply to the Arab world which didn't
need such a demonstration it after all
is aware of it it was a demonstration of
imperial power to the world at large to
the Europeans to the Far Eastern State
saying this is what we are and the
reason for this demonstration of
military power was essentially to make
up for the economic growing economic
weakness of the empire that be fear of
the senior ideologues in the Bush
administration and before that in the
Clinton administration there is a much
greater continuity between these two
than is imagined many of the things
incidentally being done by the Bush
administration today were pioneered by
the by the Clinton administration
getting the country ready for war moving
in and sending US troops to create new
bases expanding NATO into Eastern Europe
imposing restrictions on civil rights
for certain groups coming into the
country all that happened during the
Clinton administration the bush people
have taken it further but there is not
such a big discontinuity as people seem
to imagine the feeling of discontinuity
comes from the rhetoric used by the Bush
administration which frightens many
people but it is on one level it has to
be said more straightforward it does say
I mean they do say what they're doing
and why they're doing it and it is
frightening but it is real embedded to
have it the put straight then disguised
and masked by phrases like humanitarian
intervention etc and it's not the first
time that great powers have behaved in
this way either Britt or the United
States or before it the british often in
order to show the rest of the world who
was the dominant bar they did things
which didn't make
rational sense I mean if you look on
mate or were immoral I mean the bombing
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki after the
second war they just at the conclusion
of the Second World War was that a
military necessity to go and bomb
destroy two Japanese cities and kill
hundreds of thousands of civilians and
leave your mark on large parts of that
country to win the war
no one believes that it was done
essentially to show the rising enemy as
they saw it the Soviet Union the big
liberation movements in China in Vietnam
in Indonesia in Korea this is what we
are capable of doing as a warning it was
a very expensive warning for the
Japanese but it was a warning to the
rest of the world the Japanese were
virtually Adam you know defeated country
already some of their people were
already sending feelers for a surrender
so it's not the case that this was
necessary and in the same way the
occupation of Iraq today is a warning to
the rest of the world by an empire which
is militarily which is disproportionate
it is militarily very strong but
economically it's much weaker than it
used to be and it sees now in a world
where capitalism exists all over the
world
rivals coming up rival economies
flourishing and it thinks ahead don't be
deceived by the fact that you have a
particularly intellectually challenged
president today to imagine that the
people behind him are stupid they are
not they think they plan they discuss
with each other and sometimes it's much
better in the interests of an empire to
have a figurehead president because then
the if you like the capitalist Politburo
behind it can actually impose its well
whereas if you have a president who's
quite dominant and strong-willed it
reduces the power of people behind him
the two presidents you've had who've
gone
on the offensive I mean the biggest
triumph of this country if you look at
it in that way was scored under Reagan
big offensive against the evil empire as
he called it upping the military threats
the military encirclement forcing the
Russians to spend a phenomenal stupidly
a massive amount of money on military
expenditure provoking them to enter into
Afghanistan so they imploded but it
happened under Reagan and under Bush his
administration has gone on the offensive
and they've gone on the offensive quite
openly and this is a message to the
world and that is why this it was
understood as such the dissensions and
disagreements that rose within the
European Union were precisely because
they knew what was being done the
Chinese didn't react that strongly but
they knew exactly what was being done
and in this situation the the actual
suffering of the Iraqi people is not
dissimilar in that sense it's not
reached that stage of the Japanese at
the end of the Second World War if you
look at the occupation of Iraq today
what is going on they assumed they would
be able to pull it off without too many
problems and the reason they assumed
that was because people told them that
they would be welcomed with flowers and
sweets this particular University has
some responsibilities in this the
academic side of it since it produced
both Paul Wolfowitz and Farrar dodge me
leading militants in the struggle for
the empire and these people were pretty
determined to push it through as was
another Iraqi collaborator Kanan machia
who had their own agenda but were
totally isolated from the people of Iraq
and it's not a question that the people
of Iraq
their leader if that had been the case
you would have added total resistance
from the beginning that wasn't the case
but Iraq is a country with its own
history with the level of national
consciousness and with a historical
memory and this is a country which has
fought the British for three decades 20s
30s or four decades 20s 30s 40s and a
large chunk of the 50s and then got rid
of the British presence in Iraq and of
the quislings the British had set up
there the difference between the British
occupation of Iraq and the American
occupation of Iraq is this that the
British because they were a traditional
colonial power had a lot of experience
in running empires in winning over
consent of a section of the population
to run the Empire of course they didn't
last that long in Iraq thirty years is
not very long in the history of empires
but the british created an indigenous
social layer in iraq on which they could
rest for thirty years this social layer
existed on two levels in the countryside
all the tribal leaders were made into
landlords given large amounts of land
and made into landlords so they had a
stake in the colonial regime in the
chance some merchant families were
lifted out of the bazaar and given
enormous privileges and a british
intelligence team which went to visit
iraq in the late 40s produced a very
interesting report which is now public
they said what we have succeeded in
doing in iraq is producing an oligarchy
of racketeers
but this was an oligarchy of iraqi
racketeers and so there was they were
provided with some social layer in that
country on which to rest the current
occupation is essentially providing an
oligarchy of american racketeers
american companies are being taken in
there to run iraq everything is being
private
as part of the neoliberal economic
agenda that's the difference with the
past that's the difference that what the
United States is doing it is doing in an
epoch of neoliberal economics and this
particular form of capitalism with which
they try to dominate the world that is
what they're doing this is not the New
Deal the New Deal confronted an enemy in
the shape of communism so they permitted
encouraged social democratic reforms put
money in to build infrastructures in
Japan and Germany to revive the economy
reduce Britain to the level of a
supplicant they had done that already
during the war through lend-lease and
once they were sure that it was done
then they helped to rebuild the
capitalist world because the big enemy
that confronted them was communism but
today no such enemy exists nothing that
exists offers a superior social vision
economic vision to capital that's their
advantage and in this they can do what
they like so you go in like a
steamroller and that's essentially
what's happening in Iraq today with the
plans to privatize the oil industry with
the plans already in motion to privatize
everything else and to do it through
foreign companies it's interesting that
bush referred to the Philippines model
as a useful model for Iraq because it
shows a total ignorance no-one's
educated him on what happened in the
Philippines when they occupied it a
hundred years ago today 102 years ago
there was a big resistance in the
Philippines 30,000 American soldiers and
in those days they were all white died
in the Philippines some of the leading
poets and intellectuals of Philippine
were executed for resisting the American
occupation and precisely it ended up in
creating a Filipino oligarchy which
oppressed the people
of those islands for a long long time to
come and wasn't got rid often still
isn't been totally got rid of it's
hardly a model what was done in the
Philippines for Iraq so what is
happening in Iraq today essentially
contrary to what the administration
believed and the advice given to them by
their rocky collaborators there has been
a resistance on two levels from the very
beginning a passive resistance on the
part of the bulk of the population and
in active military resistance on the
part of different groups and
organizations including but not
exclusively remnants of the old regime
and one reason for their resistance of
the remnants is that the United States
did something in Iraq which from their
point of view was totally stupid they
disbanded the Iraqi army stopped paying
300,000 soldiers their wages these are
trained people they knew where the arms
were and many of them in now
decentralized without work started the
resistance in different parts of the
country this is something incidentally
which the United States did not do in
Italy Germany or Japan where by and
large a bulk of the old state apparatus
was incorporated into the occu
structures of the occupation then built
up again to take over those countries
the top people were removed except in
Japan where the emperor was kept on as a
symbol of stability against the rising
labor movement but by and large in the
other parts in Germany and Italy they
removed the people at the top but people
on the middle levels were all
incorporated Italian towns were packed
with fascists in the administration for
many many years this was the basis of
the the Christian democracy in Italy for
a long time to come in Iraq they didn't
do that I mean from their point of view
it was very foolish because a chunk of
that army would could if they
kept it on the payroll prude probably
have worked for them of course I'm not
sure but probably would have done it
just for material reasons but they
didn't do that they thought they could
destroy the Iraqi state just like that
and they did and there's nothing in its
place that is why the resistance has
grown many Western journalists have
reported that lots of ordinary Iraqis
come and say to them after the first
Gulf War Saddam Hussein had water
electricity running within two weeks
because he had a state to do it with if
you destroy the state if you put nothing
in its place except a very thin layer of
collaborators it's impossible to to get
the situation right or even return that
country to a semblance of normality they
haven't been able to do that and so the
resistance is increasing every single
day that they the claims of the
resistance are true they're not
exaggerating they are saying we're going
to make sure that their casualties of
occupying soldiers every single day one
feels incredibly sorry for the poor
American soldiers who've been sent there
by the politicians to die why should
they be there and when American soldiers
speak they speak up courageously it's
been reported in in The New York Times
and occasionally on television and what
do they say look at there's a New York
Times issue last week a soldier back on
furlough we were misled we were told we
were going there as liberators the
people hate us this is what was so
elementary that for them not to
recognize it is just staggering you know
it's not a very surprising thing it
doesn't require too much intelligence to
just recognize that an imperial
occupation of a country is not a popular
thing for the people of that country
think about it they don't like to be
occupied it's not a big surprise
especially when the occupation comes
totally complete with a neoliberal
economic apparatus so you can't deliver
anything to the people anyway in this
situation all you have is a resistance
and this resistance is spreading at
first Dick Cheney said oh it's totally
tiny pockets we will buna clear it out
in a few months there's no problems at
all the media is exaggerating well is it
seven months later where are we the
resistance is growing and the only
reason the armed resistance can prevail
is because of the support that exists
for it in the population at large
no one is naming names very few people
are betraying the resistance and without
that it couldn't exist because it's a
you know country where people know
what's going on and this resistance will
continue so you now have a dual
occupation in the Middle East you have
the occupation of Iraq and you have the
occupation of Palestine and this will
create mayhem in the years to come
unless it stopped and the only people
who can stop it are people who are
resisting and they resist in their own
ways but people in the United States who
got to take on the politicians the
resistance is already forced politicians
to rethink - in a tiny way I'm prepared
you know it one can't prove this but if
there had been no resistance in Iraq if
they had had it all their own way I
don't think any democratic politician
would have opened his or her mouth the
only reason they are speaking up a tiny
bit is because of the resistance it's
not going well
and it won't go well and they have to
speak up even more me I remember in the
days of the Vietnam War you had four or
five senators Wayne Moores Fulbright etc
who were constantly putting the
administration under
now there seems to be no one even the
ones who speak up do it in a completely
pathetic fashion instead of taking on
the lies systematically in taking on the
administration these sort of politicians
seem to have disappeared they don't seem
to exist of the citizens of the United
States have to do some of this
themselves they can't remain passive and
I always tell people in Europe that
there is opposition to this war in
America in the United States we've seen
it on the streets it's not organized
it's not consistent but it's there
people are nervous people know that they
were lied to and they've been led into
this trap and it's a classic first
resistance first stage of an armed
resistance to occupation that you're
seeing in Iraq it's no different from
Vietnam no different from Algeria that's
how they start it's much more advanced
than I thought it would be I thought it
would take at least six months for the
resistance to get going instead it's
happened very quickly
so what are the options for them and
incidentally the one argument used which
really makes me angry is when the
apologists for the occupation including
professors employed by American
universities say the real problem in
Iraq is the people excuse me you say
they say repeat it the problem is that
these people were under a dictatorship
for so long that they've become sick
that's why they're not seeing that what
we're doing for them is actually a
liberation there are people saying this
and this talk is widespread in official
circles in the United States
kanan machia one of the guys writing the
new constitution of Iraq and total
isolation from the people of Iraq said
this on NPR a few weeks ago the people
of Iraq are traumatized bloody right
they are they're traumatized by being
occupied
that's what's traumatizing them they
have their own ways of resisting Saddam
Hussein the notion that the people of
Iraq were passive the sanctions made
them more dependent on the regime that's
true but there was widespread criticism
of the regime lots of things going on
underground culturally even it's not the
case that it had a total grip the time
the regime was at its most repressive
was in this late 70s and 80s when it was
a close ally of the West and Donald
Rumsfeld went to calling on Saddam
Hussein to try and win some contract for
his company that's when the regime was
at its most repressive it was at its
most repressive when it was unleashed
against Iran to try and defeat the
Iranians after the United States lost
control of that country that's when
Saddam was at its most repressive that's
when he was being armed by the West but
this repression everyone knows it over
the last ten years has been completely
on the decline so the people far from
being traumatized were knew what was
coming
with this occupation they were prepared
for it and they didn't welcome it the
only images that exist of the so-called
liberation have had to be manufactured
the tearing down of the statue carried
out by 200 paid people paid by the
United States to do it in a city of
millions 200 people and this is meant to
be a repeat of the Berlin Wall and this
images then was played they don't use it
now because everyone seen what it was a
big square this let's say the size of
this room and in a tiny corner few
people are just getting to pull the
statue which they can so an American
machinery and equipment has to come to
take it down and this image was used as
an image of liberation or the sort of
atrocious way in which they played up
the Jessica Lynch business how she was
you know rescued when actually she was
rescued by Iraqis who helped her
because she was injured in a car
accident and these lies that are being
told can't be challenged on the same
level because no one can compete with
that particular power the major media
channels have I mean if you you know
watching the United States media is
really a culture shock if you come from
Europe it really is I mean the main
networks I don't even talk about Fox TV
that's just a joke
they're pretty awful one but if you look
at the main networks the news reports on
them are awesome no different from
propaganda what is known as propaganda
there's very little objective reporting
going on this recent upsurge in karbala
where US soldiers had to go and fight
some of the Shiite clerics big enemies
of Saddam Hussein the report on the
networks was atrocious and actually the
journalists had to say I really don't
know what's going on because what I've
heard is from the Pentagon sources here
I haven't been to the region itself this
is what I'm saying and but he broadcast
it as if it were the truth whereas in
reality what happened is that these
pathetic Eastern European soldiers poles
Ukrainians Bulgarians in these barracks
in southern Iraqi towns just think of it
what the hell are the poles doing in
Najaf or the Bulgarians in Karbala what
the hell are they doing there but the
one thing they know is not to fight
because they don't want to die which one
can respect they shouldn't be there in
the first place but they refused to come
out onto the streets and take on this
year so the US Army had to be sent
people were killed on both sides
the first big clash in Karbala the
holiest city of the Shiite sect within
Islam which indicates that this
resistance is not going to go away now
the argument which often comes up is ok
maybe the war was wrong maybe we
shouldn't have gone in but now that we
are there don't you think we should stay
in because if we came
it would be a disaster but excuse me it
is a disaster because you're in there
coming out would not be a disaster
coming out would compel the different
fractions within Iraq to set up a
national government and sort out their
own future that is what is known as
national self-determination but the
United States are now so desperate that
they're putting pressure on the Turkish
army to come in and take the hits I mean
every sturm i mean the most stupid
mistake to make in my opinion you get
the Turks in you want them to come into
the baghdad region to take the hits so
that US soldiers lives are saved but the
Turks aren't dumb they want to police
the Kurdish region because some of their
own Kurds from Turkey you've taken
refuge there and they want to settle
their own accounts and the Kurds are
saying if the Turkish army comes in at
all we might join the resistance and if
the Kurds joined the resistance well and
the Shiites in the South already
preparing for that then its endgame I'm
afraid there is no way the United States
will be able to control Iraq linked to
this and so this big demonstration of
imperial power has gone badly wrong
that's the irony that's what it was
intended for but it's gone
wrong so they cannot invade Syria and
Iran they can encourage the Israelis to
go and soften them up with a few bombing
raids but a direct military intervention
of Syria Iran would be suicidal now it
would require introducing the draft in
the United States of America in order to
do that because people will stop joining
the army and if they introduce the draft
well I think the resistance in
opposition in this country will
quadruple because people will suddenly
say do we want to go and die there in
these wars which this regime this
administration has taken us into so I
think myself I may be wrong I hope I'm
right
that the planned excursion
into Syria and Iran have gone and if
they thought it's quite interesting in
an off-the-record briefing with three
senior journalists Tony Blair Prime
Minister of Britain still said in in
this briefing when the journalist said
well where are the weapons of mass
destruction and Blair said you don't get
it do you
and they said excuse us what do you mean
Prime Minister and he said the reason we
took Iraq was so that future Wars
wouldn't be necessary just the pressure
from the West would force regime change
well that's not going to happen is it
the pressure from this botched up
occupation of Iraq is going to force
regime change in Syria and Iraq I don't
think so I don't think so
in fact what it's done is completely
isolate the West if you took a vote
amongst the populations of that part of
the world a democratic vote 90 percent
of the population would be against the
occupation not just of Iraq but of every
other country in that world with the
exception of Israel the one by-product
of this was that they neocon faction in
the administration which is strongly
allied to the Likud Party in Israel took
advantage of this to settle accounts on
behalf of Likud Ariel Sharon said after
the fall of Baghdad to the Palestinians
you Palestinians had better come to your
senses because your great protector has
gone just because Saddam gave some money
to the Palestinians as if that was
fueling the struggle as if the struggle
isn't fueled by the basic injustice of
what happened in that part of the world
many years ago something which Israeli
arrogance still refuses to recognize
that's why that struggle is going on and
it will go on and as long as the
occupation of Iraq and Palestine
continues there will be violence there
will be an increase in terror attack
it's not going to be very helpful if the
real aim was to try and reduce the
spread of terror which they claimed was
the real aim so in this situation what
is to be done here
get rid of bush which is the big
argument I hear everywhere I travel in
the United States well that would be a
start but what will you get in his place
that's another problem a four-star
general retired who seems to be the main
contender for the Democratic Party well
if he were to pull out and he were to
say that he would organize a pullout
from Iraq I would be in favor but he
doesn't say that nor do any of the
others they don't say that they say yeah
the war was wrong it was misconceived we
would have done it better because what
Bush did was he may waged war
unilaterally we would have done it
multilaterally but I ask why would that
have made the war correct if they'd been
French in German contingents forming
part of the occupation or un backing why
would that have made the war correct I
just don't understand the logic and nor
do most people I mean the notion of a
Western community acting on behalf of
civilization is a myth and this is what
the late Edward sayed good friend who
died recently in whose loss I mourn
together with many others used to warn
us about all the time
in Orientalism and other books he said
that when imperialist suppositions I
paraphrase but that was his general
argument that when imperialist
suppositions are transformed into
universal truths for Humanity
ideological domination plays a very
strong part in it and therefore Western
ideology has to be examined very closely
and he was right and it's interesting
that this one guy who made all these
points I've never seen such a vicious
set of obituaries in the LA Times in the
New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal done saying
on his grave well it shows he was pretty
effective and it also shows he has many
lives ahead of him if one guy could
frighten them so much just one guy who
was never put on the mainstream networks
because he was an articulate Palestinian
totally went against the grain of this
image of a Palestinian as a terrorist
that's all the United States thinks of
the Palestinians so in this world I
think one cannot depend on politicians
to do it I think change will come and
change will come when movements from
below challenge the visa politicians and
it's always been like that the big
movement which finally brought the
Vietnam War to an end
there was a dialectical
interrelationship between the struggles
of the Vietnamese and the anti-war
movement here and finally u.s. soldiers
said we ain't going to fight anymore
they just said it and it will probably
happen quickly here if the resistance
continues on in Iraq and that's why I
think they will be desperate to try and
find face-saving solutions because the
alternatives even with Iraq are mass
demoralization inside the US Army
because they will let jaqen they're
under false pretenses and they can see
it
so I appeal to you all as I do whenever
I come to this country which I do often
because I I think what happens in this
country is decisive in many ways and
what happens in the anti-war movement in
dissenting voices to speak up not be
cowered down 9/11 was used to try and
crush dissent in this country four
months after it there was you know you
could only speak the truth in whispers
in many campuses and streets that period
is now gone people are beginning to see
how 9/11 was used by this administration
for their own purposes which they didn't
even try don't even try and hide anymore
but this offensive they've waged this
Imperial offensive they've waged to
protect and preserve their own interests
and to defend what they think defend the
long term
a position of the United States in the
world I mean this is not going to work
incidentally all empires are capable of
over stretch especially empires which
are not so strong economically and so
there's a lot to play for there's no
reason for gloom and doom and despair
but you have to understand that you have
to play your part as alert and vigilant
citizens in this country it's not true
that the United States is on the edge of
fascism only nonsense like that which
one hears in some places it's nonsense I
mean awful things are being done and
they have to be resisted and they should
be resisted but one shouldn't sort of
completely withdraw inwards that's all I
have to say thanks
[Applause]
I'm happy to take questions so yeah the
state of the anti-war movement
the answers were written right now is
not too different from the anti-war
movement in the United States or
anywhere else that you had this was an
unusual movement in the sense that you
had a massive upsurge before the war
commenced normally anti-war movements
develop during or in the course of Wars
this movement developed before the war
and the reason for that was that large
numbers of people who came out genuinely
believed many of them had never
participated in any public activity
before leave alone demonstrations that
was what was very noticeable about the
movement that though its organizing
corps may have been on the left the bulk
of the people who came out weren't they
were ordinary citizens fed up angry it
being deceived and lied to and they
wanted to stop the war and when the war
went ahead anyway and Iraq was occupied
there was a great deal of demoralization
angle alienation but also demoralization
and people felt you know there's we
can't do anything anymore and now you
have a second spurt because of the Iraqi
resistance demonstrations are beginning
again Blair's being confronted I'm you
know your great president is visiting
Britain shortly and at first the White
House wanted a triumphant procession in
that usual British carriage with the
Queen
driven by white horses through Whitehall
but now they're saying they can't
guarantee his security if that happens
because such massive demonstrations are
being planned then the White House said
well at least the president will address
the House of Commons this is being
negotiated but the black government is
nervous because half the parliamentary
Labour Party if said they will walk out
so it will be a helicopter visit where
he'll be taken from one side to the
other in helicopters in the country in
Europe which is his closest ally and
Blair himself is now a hated and
despised
figure in the country no one takes him
seriously none of the shows he puts on
are taken too seriously in fact many
people feel he should come and live here
if the administration here could find
some work for him because what he wanted
to do is become president of the
European Union but the Europeans won't
buy him now secondhand goods yeah she
would be in the best interest to show
display military mind how is that our
long-term interest I don't see us as
what I I didn't get your perceived a
show of military might be our long-term
interest how so
oh how so in the sense that there was a
very interesting discussion which took
place in the administration of Bush
Senior the same personnel by the way are
involved in this administration with the
exception of Bush Senior and an Afghan
American very much part of the security
advisors Salma Khalilzad wrote a little
pamphlet whose title I forget but the
argument in that pamphlet written soon
after the Gulf War was the following
argument he said we no longer have
communism that's gone we now have a
world in which we have we are dominant
but we have rivals but what if one of
these rivals he meant competitive rivals
capitalist rivals what if one of these
rivals in the future got out of control
and actually challenged us economic
hegemony he didn't talk about
challenging military hegemony cuisine
that's well nigh impossible
the question is he's asked would we use
military force to crush such a challenge
and the answer he gave was yes we have
to do it in order to show our future
rivals that we're not going to let that
happen
and you know there are think tanks in
this country who constantly thinking of
dreaming of
fictional science fiction projects
almost of how to balkanize China if it
gets too big for its boots do you go via
Taiwan or Tibet the Chinese are totally
aware of this and have their own plan so
just this is what I was trying to say to
you that these people do think
strategically all empires have people
like that you know I'll give you an
example just to show you what I mean
when I talk about imperial power when
Britain was occupied by the Romans
centuries ago there was an episode
recorded by the Roman historian Tacitus
in which he was in Britain where his
father-in-law
Agricola was the governor of Britain who
in charge of the occupation of Britain
and he recalls in his memoirs of that
period he says on one occasion Tacitus
looked in the direction of what is we
know his island and said what are those
places which lied to the north of
Britain and his advisers replied these
are very backward places inhabited by
primitives they've just bought lands is
nothing worth there so don't even think
about it meaning there's nothing of
worth economically there lay so
irrelevant to us and Agricola asked but
who occupies it and he was told the
local people so he said it's not under
Rome and they said no and he said that's
very bad because an unoccupied country
sets an example to those who are
occupied and the occupation of Iraq
leaves Syria as the only unoccupied
country in the region all the other
countries in that particular region are
in the pocket of the United States so
that's how they think even regionally
and more important globally the fact
that it's going wrong is you know
interesting but they didn't imagine it
would go wrong that was what they
intended to do yeah Israel
it stands from Egypt Euphrates and
stated in Genesis do you think this war
on Iraq was launched in order to further
Israeli interests no I think as I
pointed out I think that was a small
element in it that the Israeli regime
regarded Iraq as a nuisance and wanted
it crushed I don't think that was the
major purpose for it and I think that
any dreams to implement greater Israel
will fail in the medium term even if
they attempt to do it if you look at
what is happening in Israel today senior
members of the Zionist establishment you
know not people anywhere connected to
the peace movement leave alone the
refuseniks who refuse to fight but
senior members of the zionist
establishment Avraham book chairman of
the Knesset till a few years ago one of
the founding fathers if you like of the
State of Israel has written an
incredibly powerful article which wasn't
published in the American press but was
published in every major European
newspaper as well as in Israel of course
and in this he said that I feel our own
country is teetering on the edge of a
big disaster because we had certain
ideals whatever other people may have
thought about them and we have now
totally betrayed our own ideals leave
alone what other people think and he
then goes further which is quite
stunning by the way he goes further and
he says if you reduce the Palestinians
to the status to which we have reduced
them as m-state then why'd you are you
surprised when you make their lives so
miserable that they want to make our
lives miserable in return and he
provides a de facto justification for
the suicide bombings that's why this
article created a big shock in Israel so
people inside Israel are beginning to
understand
that if they carry on occupying the post
67 war territories and carry on
harrassing and repressing the
Palestinians and no one believes that
this is an equal fight in they could I
mean you know what I find most cynical
when you debate with Israeli ideologues
which I do regularly they say yeah but
ok you know more Palestinians have died
in Israelis but you think if we wanted
to we couldn't wipe out all of them I
said well let's not go down that road of
course you could but what do you think
would happen you think people are just
watch it in the region but so it's a
very polarized situation inside Israel
itself today which we have to understand
so to make try and occupy other parts of
the Arab world I think will not be
acceptable you know I think even the
United States would be forced to draw
back from such a plan though by and
large they go along with them yeah I'm
interested you know in the time I mean
if you could say in a time of the Cold
War when when communism the real
contender in certain countries that were
casting off imperialism you know if you
look in countries like the Congo orange
Vietnam platoon which you mentioned you
know there could be opposition from
America to a popular vote because there
was fear of you know communism having
popular roots but in Iraq what do you
think what do you think the the real
fear of the Bush administration is now
now that they've you know quote-unquote
won what is it what is it what is the
Bush administration fear in having a
popular vote or allowing a popular
Constitution to come about are they
afraid of it Islamic state or what
different well I mean you know if you
look at it here you come to what happens
in countries like this it is a very rich
oil-rich state and in oil-rich countries
historically I both the British Empire
and the American Empire do not like
democratically elected governments
because if your country is rich in oil a
democratically elected government wants
to preserve control of that oil and use
it for its own purposes whatever they
may
this is not in the interest of the
empire you know and it's got nothing to
do with democracy or human rights a year
before they invaded Iraq exactly a year
before that they tried to topple the
government of hygge Chavez in Venezuela
he was not just elected once he would
been elected six different times by the
people of Venezuela he had pushed
through the most democratic constitution
in Latin America yet they tried to
topple him why because he was trying to
break the stranglehold of a corrupt
group of people over the oil industry in
order to use the oil money for providing
elementary human resources for the poor
shelter school health education basic
social democratic demands which were
acceptable in the old days to virtually
everyone including the United States not
acceptable now in this epoch so they
tried to topple him and an elected
government in Iraq if it was a genuine
election what if it said the first thing
it demanded was the exit of all
occupation soldiers not a single foreign
army on our soil the second thing it
demanded was Iraqi control over a rocky
oil saying this would be state
controlled what would they do
they'd have to push through another
regime change very very quickly and it
would backfire and what if they went
beyond that and said the bulk of our
population shares a great deal in common
with the bulk of the Iranians both in
terms of oil resources and our needs and
religion and culture and we want a joint
security pact with Iran and a common
agreement on economic political social
matters how would that be greeted it
would create an absolutely giant state
in the region even if they didn't unite
not in the interests of the United
States so the only democracy they will
permit will be if they do any at all
it will be strictly controlled just like
the British did it
the British organized an election when
they controlled Iraq two-thirds of the
seats were uncontested all the
landlord's won which is why pee
or have a genuine contempt for this
style of democracy as well yeah after
the war even was before it became very
obvious that Saddam's murderer his own
people sorry
Saddam was a brutal dictator perfect his
own people would you admit down any
level it's a good thing that he was
removed from power
I think people of the country should
have the only they're the only people
who have the right to remove their
dictators as I pointed out the bulk of
the repression that's why they couldn't
show any images of this the bulk of the
repression took place in the 80s
throughout that decade when he was a
very close ally of your government and
the West when he was a close ally they
were dealing with him economically
arming him his scientists his military
were being trained in in the Academy in
in Britain for a start why didn't they
put to use the influence they had with
him to pressure him at that time saying
don't do this don't do this it's not
good they didn't do it that was the time
they could have done it if they were
genuinely interested the bulk that's
when the bulk of the repression took
place not over the last five years so
sorry regardless of the reason why yeah
you know you it's pointless invading a
country when you create a bigger mess
than existed before there are now more
prisoners in Iraq than they were under
the last year's of the Saddam regime
more people have been locked up in
prison it's for many people and the
punishments they're inflicting on people
they suspect of being in the resistance
are brutal you attack their families you
lock them up you destroy their homes
we've seen the evidence for it this is
its classic colonial occupation from
that point of view and that's why
they're nervous they don't have very few
actual Iraqis that they trust
not even to clean the u.s. army barracks
imported South Asian and Philippi
new immigrants to do that yeah you
mentioned beginning you talked about two
factors one allowing to pull back 267
border well is the autonomy of a stage
as being very very crucial as well as
pulling out around yeah now given that
anyway there's been so much damage do
you have any further suggestions about
blimp movers now that may be helpful
wanted to stop a sort of generative
generative sort of terrorism that's
going on sort of moving into certain
organizations of the things like that so
in other words political situations
before are very different than what
there are going to be now you have some
suggestions well I did you know I think
the only suggestion one can make is to
repeat what one said but I mean the
United States has phenomenal pressure it
could exercise on Israel you know not
military pressure political economic to
pull them back they could do it but they
don't want to do it and this regime like
the Clinton regime is packed with
partisans of Israel's I mean so in this
recent election campaign Howard Dean
says once we should be even-handed to
the Palestinians and the Israel even
handed when once occupying someone
else's lands instead but even that is
unacceptable and he's forced to retreat
on that very very quickly and if this is
the atmosphere then it's unlikely that
they will do anything on Israel as far
as Iraq is concerned you now have a full
you know a sort of first stage
resistance struggle as I pointed out
which is different from terrorism it's
not terrorism basically they're trying
to get the occupation Army's out of
their country everyone those countries
have been occupied have used these
tactics Europeans use them against the
fascists in Italy in France the
resistance movements did many of these
things including blowing up cafes where
occupation soldiers were sitting the
Algerians did it in France and the
Rocky's will do it in Iraq that's not a
big surprise and I think there were you
know the interesting thing is the other
thing which I didn't talk about it's
only in this country that a large chunk
of the population believed Saddam
Hussein had links with al-qaeda no one
anywhere else in the world believes this
and the politicians elsewhere in the
world don't even want to try it on
because the populations are better
informed and the politicians know know
what people will laugh but here Bush got
away with it and still repeats this
nonsense it's a total and complete
nonsense so it was the weapons of mass
destruction and the Al qaeda-linked that
were the main excuses used to go to war
it wasn't Saddam's repression this
wasn't designated as a humanitarian
intervention but as a preemptive strike
and self-defense that's how they
characterized it to get around the UN
Charter an international law but that's
now been proved to be a total joke so in
fact there is a prima facie case a real
legally senior attorneys in Britain say
that there is a prima facie case to try
bush and Blair at the international war
crimes court of course they can't be
tried because of who they are but there
is a case yeah
you agree with we're talking a lot about
the motivations for getting a Brock
would you agree that one motivation
might be to just create an artificial
ally in a hostile region sort of like
what happened with Kuwait and wake of a
night of the first Gulf War first gun
fool you mean what did you say the first
yeah well I think obviously occupying it
that was also and I don't think that was
the main motivation the main motivation
is as I described it but a subsidiary
plan was to create in Iraq State which
they could use rather than being over
dependent in Saudi Arabia but that's not
going to work you know this is where
they made a very big mistake in going
for Iraq they thought that the
population will rise and greet them as
liberators and that's not going to
happen yeah let's have one last question
yeah
sorry you have yep Middle Eastern
problem first let me tell you some
things I agree with when Theodore Herzl
went to Palestine he didn't notice that
there are other people already living
there for two thousand years this is the
fundamental problem one of my Jewish PhD
colleagues at the State Department said
the problem is almost insoluble because
you've got two parties who believe that
God often promised them the same piece
of territory third I never thought after
taking courses on fascism and
dictatorships in graduate school
entirely I would see somebody applying
dr. gurgles theories of propaganda but
it's been used brilliantly by this
current administration his theory was
telling no small lies
nobody would believe you you have to
tell whoppers these big ones and
persistence and sometimes you can notice
when President Bush tells a really big
whopper there is a unique glint in his
eyes also the thing is that the
Palestinians have always been used as
the wedge against Israel by the other
Arab countries they don't give a damn
about the Palestinians they have never
given a pennant not a penny to the
relief fund it takes care of the people
in those camps the United States has
always paid 78 percent of it and they
are opposed to Israel
because this is a modern technological
democratic society a lot of fatality
mistake and I think we've got to do
something and I am the power going
through every way about the Wahhabism
and the madrasa schools which are
spreading all of these distorted
feelings about the nature of Islam
because Islam at one time was a very
leading civilized country or movement it
had people from Christianity and Judaism
in all its university it did not treat
women as property of men and they've
been dead for six hundred years which is
too bad and the idea that you can go
backwards instead of forwards I think
very common seductive to their own
long-term future all cation say yeah
didn't work worth in the a bomb was not
used in Japan although revisionists
think so to warn the Russians and so on
if you read the official World War two
histories of the army they were
anticipating between two and three
million American dead in the occupation
of Japan and they estimated that at
least six million Japanese were going to
die and gentlemen garter kept pushing
John Marshall to get the Russians in
Civil War otherwise he said he would
demand of American forces there and we
actually cinder eyes the hell of a lot
more people in our firebombing of Tokyo
than were killed
to records okay well I mean we can agree
to disagree on that there's a big
discussion which goes on endlessly about
the reason why the nuclear weapons were
used in in in Japan I think when you say
that they was talkin Tsar declared war
on Japan precisely to prevent the
Russians from coming in to share in that
country and occupy together with the
United States ie the so-called communist
threat which began even before the
second world war was over played a major
part in the use of those weapons it's a
different way of putting it as far as
Israel and the Arab world is concerned I
think most of the Arab world accepts
that Israel is there to stay it is a
colonial settler state but with a
difference in the sense that the bulk of
that population has no mother state to
return to as was the case in previous
colonial empires doesn't justify what
happened but they are prepared to accept
it provided that the Israelis accept
that what they did to the Palestinians
in 1948 was a dreadful crime uprooting
them from their villages destroying
their villages driving them out and
providing some compensation to the
families who've lost homes and property
there but they don't even begin to say
that instead they constantly demonize
the Palestinians but the second part of
that is that we have to have a
Palestinian state with continuous
territory with its own borders with its
own rights without Israeli settlers
without Israeli tanks permanently
overlooking Palestinian towns in other
words a proper Palestinian state which
is not an Israeli Protectorate that's
the key if that were done I think it
would lay the basis for coexistence in
the future because as you point out
yourself in your right historically even
though many Israeli hard core Israelis
like Netanyahu xenia constantly try to
find stories of permanent victimized
station of the Jewish people there have
been periods in history where
coexistence took place and there was
very little or no repression the period
in Islamic Spain where the Muslims of
the ruling class in Spain was a period
where Jews were treated like anyone else
and rose to high positions within the
structures of that state when the
barbarian Crusaders from Europe went and
occupied the Arab lands took Jerusalem
destroyed synagogues in the temple burnt
Jews alive burnt Muslims alive the
Muslim leader who took Jerusalem back
and made it a free city for all three
religions gave state subsidies for the
synagogue's to be built was an Arab
leader called Salafi so historically
these two religions have not been
engaged in wars against each other for
hundreds of years they've worked with
each other what changed that was a
political thing not ethnic not religious
well a political decision to create the
State of Israel which wouldn't have
happened without the total support in
the crucial period not the later period
crucial support of the British Empire
and the Balfour Declaration of 1917
which said that they could create a
state there are many many very decent
Jewish thinkers argued for a cultural
presence in the Middle East they said we
shouldn't have a political presence
because in many farsighted thinker said
if we establish a political presence in
the Middle East it will force us to
become oppressors we should have a
cultural presence and live with the
people who are already here this was of
course rejected by the Zionists and all
I say to you is this that the horrible
Judea side of the second world war left
its mark on Europe but it also created
indirect victims who are the
Palestinians who are paying the price so
thank
tariq Ali is on the editorial board of
new left review bush in Babylon the
recolonization of Iraq is published by
verso on the web at verso books calm
[Music]